اهلا بكم متلاحقه سريعه لافته ومثيره
للجدل والقلق ايضا هكذا يمكن وصف تطورات
قضيه تيران وصنا
وهما جزيرتان كانتا تحت سياده المصريه منذ
فج التاريخ واصبحت سعوديتين بحكم تصديق
الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي ولما يمضي على
توليه السلطه غير ثلاث سنوات فكما كانت
الدهشه من اسراع مجلس النواب في اقرار
اتفاقيه تقضي بالتخلي عن جزء من الارض ومن
تدخل المحكمه الدستوريه لتعليق تنفيذ
احكام القضاء المتعلقه بالجزيره كانت صدمه
مصريه من توقيت تصديق الرئيس السيسي على
نقل السياده على تيران وصنافير
للسعوديه تقرير محمد
نصر تيران وصنافير مصريه بالدم وبالتاريخ
وبجرافيك
النخاع يقول عسكريون وسياسيون ومتخصصون في
التاريخ
والوثائق لكن بجره قلم من الرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي نقلت تباعيه الجزيرتين
من غرب البحر الاحمر الى شرقه بعد موافقه
الحكومه ثم البرلمان في مشهد مثير للجدل
اعلن موافقه المجلس على اتفاقيه ترشيم
الحدود عشيه عيد الفطر اذا اصبحت
الجزيرتان السعوديتين بجهد مصري خالص
توقيت عبقري لتمرير اتفاقيه بهذا الحجم
قبل ساعه من اذان اخر مغرب في رمضان
والمصريون منشغلون بشراء مستلزمات العيد
مؤسسات الدوله متوق فه تماما بسبب العطله
الرسميه حملات اعتقال استباقيه لعشرات
النشطاء وتعزيزات امنيه في اغلب ميادين
[تصفيق]
القاهره فلا تتوقع تجمعا هنا او هناك يعكر
صفو من وقع او من
تسلم
الار من المصريين من قال ان السيسي فرت في
الارض فرد اخرون بان الحق عاد الى اصحابه
وان مصر كانت تحتل ارضا سعوديه ايا كانت
الاراء فقد تجاوزها الزمن بعد تصديق
السيسي لكن الاحتقان الشعبي الذي سببته
تلك القضيه بات امرا لابد من التوقف عنده
فرغم الشرخ الذي ضرب نسيج المجتمع المصري
منذ الانقلاب ثمه اجماع بين معارض السيسي
وعدد من مؤيديه على خطوره ما جرى من تفريط
في الارض كما يصفونه ثمت اي ايضا علامات
استفهام كثيره بشان عوده شخصيات ذات ثقل
سياسي وعسكري الى الواجهه من جديد كالفريق
سامي عنان وعمرو موسى وحمدين صباحي
والتصريح برفضهم لتلك الاتفاقيه لكن لم
يلتفت السيسي الى هذه التصريحات ولم يستمع
اصلا للقوى السياسيه الرافضه للاتفاقيه
واوصى الابواب في وجه
الجميع الموضوع خلص لكن انا بتكلم فيه لان
احنا مع ما دناش حاجه نخبيها خلاصه القول
طيران وصنافير سعوديتان ما يصحش مساحه
المملكه زادت بنحو 80 كيلو مترا بعد ايام
فقط من تولي الامير محمد بن سلمان ولايه
العهد اما مصر فقد خسرت ارضا يراها كثيرون
استراتيجيه ومصريه بحته بشهاده قاده
سابقين جزيره طيران مصريه وبشهاده نواب
حاليين
مصر مصر وباتت نغمه واحده هي سائده وانت
يا سيسي رجال وعظي تستاهل مليون سكريم من
كل مصر لك ورده على الاراده وع
[موسيقى]
التصميم لمناقشه الموضوع ينضم الينا من
القاهره عبر الهاتف كل من المستشار احمد
مكي وزير العدل السابق و محمود ابراهيم
نائب رئيس مركز الاتحاديه للدراسات ومن
برلين عبر سكايب الدكتور احمد بدوي
الاكاديمي المصري والباحث في قسم العلوم
السياسيه بالجامعه الحره في برلين اهلا
بكم جميعا مستشار مكي بتصديق الرئيس
السيسي هل ينتهي الجدل
قانونيا اعتقد ان الجدل ينتهي عشان على
الواقع الشعبي فغضب المصري كامن
ولابد ان يكون له اثر على مدى قريب او
بعيد سنلمس اثرا وعلى المستوى القانوني
القضيه لم تحسب يعني حتى لو فرضنا ان
المحكمه الدستوريه قالت ان هذه المسائل
تتسق بالسياده ف الاتفاقات التي تتسق
بالسياده بنص الدستور في الماده 151 في
فقرتها الثانيه
توجب ان لا يتم التصديق عليها الا بعد
استفتاء
الشعب دعنا نسلم بان هذه الجزد لم تكن
مصريه لكن مارست مصر السياده عليها ودي
مساله ثابته بقرارات مجلس الامن سابكه
بحرب 67 و73 والجداد كله سبقا اتفاقيه
بديف نفسها وبالتالي لابد ان هيكون في
دعوه تطعن على قرار التصديق واعتباره قرار
اداري وتقول انه تم بالمخالفه ل الفقره
الثانيه من الماده 151 في ماده 157 من
الدستور بتقول لرئيس الجمهوريه ان يستفتي
الناس في المسائل الهامه ا و فيش اهم من
من قضيه التفريط والسياده على مضيق العقل
ا اللي خدنا بسببه عده حروب واللي روحنا
بسببه مجلس الامن فده استخفاف بط الناس ان
يتم التصديق وبغير سف حتى طيب انقل هذه
الافكار للسيد محمد ابراهيم استمعت الى
المستشار مكي لماذا يضرب الرئيس السيسي
عرض الحائط القانون الراي السياسي الراي
الشعبي ولماذا هذا الاصرار والاسراع في
نقل تبعيه تيران وصنافير الى المملكه
العربيه
السعوديه يعني انا اتصور ان احنا في لحظه
زي لحظه الموافقه على اتفاقيه 77 في
البرلمان المصري حتى هذه اللحظه هناك
كثيرين من جماعه الاخوان ومن المعارضين
السياسيين اغلبهم المرضين لهذه اقيه ايضا
يعتبروا ان اللي حصل وفقا للاتفاقيه دي
اللي هي المعروفه ب كان بديفيد تفريط
وخيانه وكذا وكل هذه المسميات الخيمه
العظيمه لكن في الحقيقه ان الدول لا تدار
هكذا يعني يعني رغمه حتى بعد التحفظ على
الاسلوب الذي تم بداره هذا الملف بشكل عام
من البدايه لكن حتى المعارضه ايضا هي
معارضه فاشله لم تقدم اي شيء ولكن الرئيس
مشي في القنوات الطبيعيه المسائل بقى
بتاعه حكم المحكمه والخلاف القانوني
المساله ليست لها علاقه بالمحاكم وواضح
انه مساله سياسيه اقرها البرلمان وصدق
عليها الرئيس وفقا لصلاحياته المحدده في
الدستور هذه في اتفا في حكم محكمه اخر
سابق على اتفاقيه وقع عليها السيسي متعلقه
بترسم الحدود وقال انه ترسم الحدود من
مسائل السياده اللي الخاصه باليونان ف هنا
في بس تصيد كده لكن في كل الاحوال انا ارى
انه ا يعني ما حدث قد حدث يعني خلاص
الاتفاقيه تدخل حي التنفيذ كل ما وراء ذلك
هو تكهنات وا يعني زعيق في الهواء يعني
مش حتى تلك التي صدرت من شخصيات سياسيه
مهمه حمدين صباحي عمر موسى سامي عنان حتى
يعني احمد شفيق وانت كنت ضمن حمله السيد
احمد
شفيق الانتخابيه هو ايضا قال ان تيران
وصنافير م
ريتان لا يا فندم من طريق احمد شفيق
وحضرتك على موقعه على تويتر على صفحته عمل
بيان من سنه وقال انه هو يعلم ان
الجزيرتين سعوديتين ولكن حينما تدخل في
مداخله تلفزيونيه مع وائل الابراشي من
حوالي اسبوع او 10 ايام هو يعني كان ليه
تحفظات على اداره الملف بشكل عام الاداره
السياسيه لكن الفريق شفيق بيانه الرسمي
بيقول انه بوز سعوديه لكن هذا امر على جنب
يعني
ب تسميهم طبعا الفريق شفيق انا يعني
احترمه واقدره جدا لكن يعني دي مساله
مرتبطه بالسلطه مش مرتبطه بالمعارضه
السياسيه يعني دي مساله خد طيب سيد احمد
بدوي طيب سيد احمد بدوي اليس من المنطقي
ايضا ان ان يصادق الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي على نقل تبعيه الجزيرتين بعد ان
صادق البرلمان ايضا على هذه القضيه التي
تعتبر سياديه لماذا سي ظر الرجل التوقيع
والتصديق على هذه
[موسيقى]
الاتفاقيه هذا سؤال صعب لان يعني بتحطني
في موقف الدفاع عن الرجل وهذا شيء لا اريد
ان افعله طبعا طالما ان البرلمان صدق على
الاتفاقيه بغض النظر عن الجدل القانوني
مافيش اي شيء يخلي رئيس الجمهوريه ينتظر
دوت من الناحيه البراجماتيه البحته لكن من
الناحيه السياس
سياسيه ومن الناحيه
الاخلاقيه الموضوع مش بس موضوع متعلق
بالسلطه اعتقد ان السلطه اساءت تقدير رد
فعل الشعب المصري على الاتفاقيه ديت الشعب
المصري ثقافيا الارض بالنسبه له شيء مقدس
طبعا ناس كتير انتقدوا طريقه اداره ملف
تيران وصنافير وده طبعا يعني شيء مهم جدا
على اقل من وجهه النظر السياسيه
طريقه اداره الملف تنم عن اسلوب ابوي في
التعامل مع الشعب المصري واعتقد ان اي حد
في السلطه في مصر كان لازم يفهم ان في شيء
اتغير في مصر بعد 2011 الاسلوب العملي
الابوي في التعامل مع الشعب هيكون له رد
فعل عكسي واعتقد ان رد فعل الشعب المصري
على الاتفاقيه جزء منه طبعا راجع للمراره
اللي كتير يعني قطاع عريض من الشعب المصري
مصري حاسس بيه نتيجه فقدان الارض لكن
اعتقد جزء كبير من رد الفعل هو رفض تام
للاسلوب الابوي اللي تم التعامل بيه مع
القضيه ديت فكره انا اخدت قرار وماحدش
يتكلم في الموضوع دوت بعد كده وما فيش
حاجه نخبيها والموضوع انتهى دي ده اسلوب
التعامل دوت مع الشعب اللي احنا يعني
وارثينه من 52 وحتى من قبل 52 لازم يكون
في ادراك من قبل السلطه ان الاسلوب دوت
اسلوب عفى عليه الزمن وهيدي لمصاعد كبيره
ولو ان ما فيش ناس نزلت تتظاهر في الشارع
مش معنى كده ان الشعب راضي معنى كده ان
وتيره القمع زادت لكن لازم يكون في ادراك
ان الغضب اللي بداخل الشعب المصري ناس
كتير جدا من اللي كانوا بيدوا السيسي
تاييد مطلق ابتدوا دلوقتي يراجعوا موقفهم
بالذات بعد الاتفاقيه دي طيب في تفضل
المستشار مكي سمعنا الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي يقول الحكايه خلصت بعدها بسوع فقط
المحكمه الدستوريه العليا تعلق تنفيذ
الاحكام احكام القضاء ما تاثير هذا على
هيبه دوله القانون على اعلى سلطه قضائيه
في مصر
بتقديرك ماده 151 اي رافع على الاتفاقيات
والرئيس ص هذه الفقره الاولى النص الثانيه
الفقره الثانيه ق الاتفاق اللي فيها ما
يتصل بالسياده او صلح يبقى لابد من
استفتاء الشعب المصري عليها حتى اتفاقيه
كم تم الاتفاق عليها صحيح في ناس في
معارضه في مقابل في دفع تمنها
الرئيسات حياته رئيس انور
سادات عن نص قانوني انا مش عارف
ازاي المستشار مكي اعتذر منك الصوت متقطع
جدا لم نستطع سماع ما تفضلت به سيد
ابراهيم اي متابع
محايد نزيه يرى ان هذه الاجراءات الغير
شعبيه التي يتخذها الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي منها الاقتصاديه الى جانب نقل
تبعيه يران وصنافير والشعبيه التي اتكل
عليها منذ الانقلاب بدات
تتاكل الا تاخذ السلطه بالحسبان مع وصول
الرئيس السيسي لسنه الثالثه في الحكم الا
تاخذ في الحسبان هذا التاكل في الشعبيه
شعبيه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي طبعا
اسمحلي في البدايه بس تحفظ على كلمه منذ
الانقلاب هو
منذ ثوره 30 يونيو
لكن فيما يخص شعبيه الرئيس اي رئيس شعبيته
بتطلع وبتنزل لانه هو طالما في السلطه
بيتخد قرارات دي مساله منطقيه
وروتين وفي ظل غياب المنافسين الجادين
للرئيس السيسي ف حتى لو شعبيته وصلت لاقل
درجه ممكن اي حد يتصورها فمافيش اي منافس
محتمل يقدر يواجهه في انتخابات وبالتالي
هو بيراهن على ده هيوصل لفين دي مساله
الايام هتكشف عنها
يعني دي مسائل بتمشي الدول برض مره تانيه
ما بتمشيش بالشكل ده
ف في النهايه هو عنده انتخابات السنه
الجايه هتبقى تجديد لشعبيته واستفتاء على
شعبيته وهنشوف ايه ايه اللي حصل والرئيس
ترامب مثلا ما هو رئيس منتخب اهو وشرعي
وماجاش زي ما حضرتك وصحت يعني ماجاش
بالانقلابات ولا الكلام ده وشعبيته في في
ادنى صورها يعني ف بتحصل يعني مشكله خالص
يعني طيب ا سييد احمد بدوي ب 30 ثانيه لو
لو امكن لو سمحت ما خيارات المعسكر الرافض
لنقل تبعيه الجزيرتين الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ا الاستمرار في الرفض
ومحاوله فهم سبب اصرار الرئيس السيسي على
نقل تبعيه الجزيرتين دول للسعوديه بسرعه
في نقاط كثيره لا نفهمها يجب ان نحاول ان
نفهمها ويجب على من يرفض ان يستمر في
الرفض بعقلانيه لان الموضوع دوت ما اعتقدش
ان هو هيعدي بسهوله الدكتور احمد بدوي
الاكاديمي المصري والباحث في قسم العلوم
السياسيه بالجامعه الحره في برلين شكرا لك
واشكر محمود ابراهيم نائب رئيس مركز
الاتحاديه للدراسات والمستشار احمد مكي
وزير العدل السابق نشكركم مشاهدنا الكرام
على المتابعه الى اللقاء بامن الله
[موسيقى]
ورعايته